Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm currently eating my lunch dinner, right?
Or lunch.
Sorry, you're gonna hear dad barking because he's trying to be like, I WANT LUNCH DINNER!
Even though he just, he literally, I literally just fed him like 20 minutes ago.
But, um...
I'm having my 5pm lunch right now, and then after the stream, I'll grab actual food.
But, basically, I finally found a bakery.
A Japanese bakery that sells, like, Japanese, special, like, Japanese, like, bread.
I don't remember exactly what they're called, but oh my gosh, I love...
Since we're open, please.
Please.
No.
No?
I figured.
It's my little snack before my actual dinner dinner.
Um, and also, like, I'm worried that...
I don't, I'm worried that my bread's gonna expire.
Because, like, I actually ordered this, like, two days ago, and I haven't, uh...
I haven't even tried the bread out yet.
No.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he's like... Yeah, I think he needs some milk for it.
No!
No.
My dog is very, um, food motivated.
Which is bad, because...
He will actually follow a criminal if he has food.
It's very bad, because if I get fucking robbed...
And the criminal was like, oh, you know, instead of protecting me...
He's gonna be like, he has food, so I guess you're gonna get shot now.
Or shanked if I'm... Or shanked or something.
And I'm a little bit worried about that.
I'm just a little worried at how food motivated he is.
He literally would follow a stranger if she had treats, like...
I told you guys this before, but don't you... Don't say that!
Like, I... I don't know what to do.
Like...
I... Literally, like...
I told you guys this story before, but, like...
You bump into this random lady, but she had, like, treats on her.
So, obviously, Ducky Amber Doge, he, like, smelled those treats.
So he got super excited, because, like...
And, like, she was, like, this dog walker that I would bump into.
And then she was, like, joking around and be like...
Uh-huh, what if I just take your leash and then walk away with it?
Do you think he'll follow me?
And he didn't look back.
He literally wagged his tail and walked away with her.
Because she had food on her.
So, I was like, oh, that's not good.
That's not good at all.
No?
No.
So, like...
So, like, I'm like, this is not good.
No?
No.
Alright.
I finished my food, so, like, he's gonna stop barking now.
Now that he knows the food is gone.
There's no food.
No food.
He's not gonna bark anymore.
Alright, you little shit.
He's loyal to his stomach.
No more food, and now he can't do anything.
Alright.
Snacking is done.
Alright!
Hello, everybody!
Today, we're gonna be playing Doraemon!
Dorayaki Shop Story.
I've been meaning to play this game for a while.
Oh my god, Doki finally not playing a Flavor of the Month game?
Oh my god, she's actually playing games that...
No, other games interest me too, but like...
Oh my god, she's playing a game that's not, like, the most popular game on Steam at the moment?
That's fucking crazy, what's wrong?
Anyway.
So, I grew up with Doraemon.
But before he was called Doraemon, he was called Ding Dong in Cantonese, in Hong Kong.
So, like, I used to watch a lot of Doraemon growing up.
And I used to read, like, the comic books and everything too.
So, he was basically a part of my childhood.
And when I saw this on Steam, I was like...
Oh!
It's Doraemon!
Oh my god, I can't wait!
I was super excited.
Because I used to be super fucking obsessed with Ding Dong growing up.
And I had, like, all the manga of it.
And I even had the official English translations of the novel.
I used to read the baseball adaptation.
Actually, read is like a stretch.
It was in Cantonese.
So, like, the text was in Cantonese.
And I had no idea what they were saying.
But I really liked the art.
I really liked the artwork.
So, I would read the baseball adaptation.
But I had no idea what was going on.
And then I used to read the...
I just tried to guess what's going on by the pictures.
And, yeah, I experienced it.
Yeah, and then I had the manga for...
I actually own...
Because back in Hong Kong, there's this really popular...
There's this really popular children's comic magazine called...
I think it was either...
I think it was Happy Dragon.
Or it was, like, Coco.
It was either Happy Dragon or Coco.
Because I used to buy those two growing up.
And they would run the baseball manga.
They would run the baseball series.
So, I would buy it every week just to read.
And they also ran the Pokemon series, too.
The really hardcore Pokemon series.
So, oh, yeah, Koro Koro.
Was it called Koro Koro?
I don't remember.
It was Happy Dragon and Koro Koro.
And I used to read...
I would buy them, like, weekly.
Actually, my dad would help buy them for me weekly.
Or I would go to news...
Oh, my gosh, I remember in Hong Kong...
I don't know if they still do that anymore.
Because, like, people don't buy news...
Like, don't buy...
Like, don't really buy magazines outside anymore.
But there would be, like, magazine stalls.
And then I would...
My dad and I...
My dad or I would buy them.
And also, like, Lou Fuzi or, like, Mr. Q.
And he would buy, like, Lou Fuzi, Happy Dragon, and Koro Koro for me.
And so, like, I would read those a lot.
As a kid, growing up.
And I remember, like, really enjoying the baseball series for one of them.
The Doraemon baseball series.
And also, like, I really enjoyed...
There's a million adaptations.
There's literally, like, a million fucking adaptations of Doraemon.
But it's not from...
It's not from, like, the original artist.
Or the original...
Like, the original, like, manga cup.
Because there was one with, like...
Like, based off of, like, the adventures of Doraemon's cousins.
And, like, they're all, like, cousins from different parts of the world.
And...
It was so interesting.
It was such an interesting concept.
And then...
And then there was, like...
I don't remember.
Yeah, there was a cousin spin.
Yeah, the Doraemon multiverse.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know he's dead, guys.
I know he's dead.
He's been... He's, like...
He's been dead for a long time.
I know that, guys.
I...
Um... Yeah.
Was it really called...
Was it, like, called the Doraemons?
I don't even remember.
I didn't... I never knew what the name of the...
Like I said, I own the manga of it.
But, like, I had no idea what was exactly going on.
I just...
I just experienced it via the pictures.
I was like, whoa, the pictures...
It looks like they're having a good time.
Like...
I just be like...
I just experienced it with the pictures and be like, whoa.
This adventure looks so cool.
I have no idea what they're saying.
But the adventures look amazing.
It looks so pretty.
And I also...
I also own the manga of the...
There was another one they did.
Where it was basically, like, Doraemon serious side.
Serious stories.
Where they would go in on, like, actual adventures and stuff.
So I had, like, the whole, like, manga of it.
It was all in Chinese.
It was all in Cantonese.
I don't remember if it was Chinese or Cantonese.
I don't remember if it was, like, in traditional or simplified.
Because, like, I bought them in, like, very...
I bought them either in Shenzhen or, like, in Hong Kong.
So I don't remember.
So...
I also own, like, the serious ones.
Where they go on actual adventures.
And I think my favorite story from those...
Because, like, I actually bought, like, the DVDs as well.
Or was it VCDs?
I don't fucking remember.
But I also had, like, the DVDs of them.
And they had, like, actual, like, English subtitles.
So I sort of knew what they were...
I didn't understand what the fuck was going on in the book.
But I knew what was going on in the movies.
Because I had English subtitles to read it from.
And, um...
And I think my favorite story in the serious ones...
Was the dinosaur.
I cried.
If anyone remembers the dinosaur story...
Oh my god, I...
I think that has to be, like, one of, like, my favorite stories.
From, like, the more serious side of Doraemon.
Because, like, um...
I won't spoil it, but it gets really sad.
At the end, it gets...
It gets so...
It gets really sad in the end.
But I don't remember what the serious was called.
But the dinosaur one was the most memorable one for me.
Um, there was one with a dog.
I forgot, like, the dog humans?
Oh my god, what was it?
The dog movie.
They made so many versions of it.
What was it?
Oh, yeah!
The one where, like, Dai Hong.
Or is it Nobita?
I think it's called, like, Nobita in Japanese, right?
But, like, I knew his name as Dai Hong.
And, like, he found, like...
He went to, like, the multiverse.
Of, like, his, like...
The multiverse.
Where, like, there's him.
But what if he was a dog?
So...
So, it was basically, yeah, the...
And then they found out that...
It was such a...
It was so interesting.
Because they found out that it wasn't a multiverse.
But it was actually, like, um, the future.
It was actually the future.
Because they sent these dogs into their own planet.
And then those dogs became human.
But then, like, it was some time travel.
It's weird.
They gave the dogs technology.
So then they evolved into dog humans.
And then, so, like, because of that...
They somehow traveled to the future.
And was like, whoa.
Whoa, like...
Who are these dogs?
So, yeah, it was like Planet of the Apes.
But Planet of the Dogs, basically.
But they also remake these movies so much.
That, like, I don't even remember which version it was that I watched.
They remake it so fucking much.
Because there's not, you know...
They can't really make new stories out of it.
So, like, I don't remember which one was the one I watched.
It must have...
It's very old.
I remember it being, like, very, very old.
Most likely the older versions.
Because I haven't watched...
The only, the most recent Doraemon movie I watched...
Was the 3D one.
And I watched it on the plane and I cried so much.
And then I remember, I told you guys this story before.
I watched the 3D one.
Where it was, like, Doraemon and you or something.
I don't remember what it's called.
And then, I was in business class.
So then I was crying my fucking eyes out watching it.
Because the ending was really, really sad.
Because I legitimately thought Doraemon was gonna leave.
Even though, I'm like, there's no way he's gonna leave.
He's literally...
The title, like...
I was like, oh my god.
What if he actually leaves for real?
And then we'll never get Doraemon anymore.
I'm like, oh my...
And I started crying.
I was like, oh my god.
He's actually gonna be gone forever.
You guys stand by me.
And I started crying.
I was like, oh my god.
This is over.
They're killing the main character off.
And we'll never see him again.
Oh my god.
He's actually never gonna come back.
And then Nobita is gonna fail as a person.
Because if he doesn't have Doraemon, he'll grow up to be a dead bee.
Oh my god.
It's the worst future he could ever have.
It's over.
And then he comes back.
And I was like, yay.
I took it.
Don't say that.
Anyway.
And then the flight attendant came over.
And was like, are you okay?
And I was like, yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
But yeah.
That's basically the last Doraemon movie I watched.
I haven't watched any of the newer stuff.
Ever since they changed the voice actor for Doraemon.
The Cantonese version.
I know it's because they had to.
To make it more faithful to the original voice actor.
To the original Japanese voice actor.
I was sad.
I was very sad.
Because I grew up with his voice acting.
I was like, no!
You're supposed to voice act Doraemon until I die.
So I don't have to live with change.
You're supposed to be his voice until I cease to exist.
So I can always keep watching Doraemon.
Felt the same.
That's why I never watched.
No, not the Japanese voice actor.
I know the Japanese voice actor.
I never grew up with a Japanese voice actress.
Sorry, voice actress.
Because I was never into.
I grew up with the Cantonese voice actor.
So that's why when I listened to the original voice acting for the first time.
I was like, this ain't right.
That's not the ding dong I know.
Oh,
yeah.
Oh, wait.
The Cantonese voice actor passed away too.
Oh, no.
No.
Why did you have to...
Oh, my God.
No.
I didn't know.
Ding Dong dies.
No.
Why didn't you know?
I want to live in the fantasy world where he's still there.
Anyway.
Like I said.
Ding Dong never dies.
It's a terrible day for Rain.
It's dry over.
This is why change is bad.
Anyway.
So I never watched the newer movies or the newer series.
Because like...
It just didn't feel the same, you know.
I just don't...
I don't know.
It's like, you know when you grow up with a certain...
I think it would be better if they got the newer voice actors sounded the same as the original.
Not the Japanese original.
My original.
Because like, you don't understand.
The Cantonese dubbing for Doraemon.
He dubbed that show for so long.
That's the voice I hear when I hear Doraemon talk.
So when the newer voice actor is now more faithful to the original Japanese version.
I was like...
I couldn't.
I couldn't adapt.
I was like...
I watched the show for so long.
I couldn't adapt to the new voice.
It was such a...
I was like, that's not him.
I know that's him in the Japanese voice acting.
But that's not him.
So I got really sad.
So I never kept up with it.
But I still love Doraemon.
I still love...
Actually, in Hong Kong, they did a special performance in Hong Kong.
Doraemon did a special show there.
And I remember my parents bringing me to the show.
I don't know what it was called.
I think it was like a special show.
I think it was like a world tour.
And it was an incredibly special show.
Because they had like...
It was like...
Oh my god.
I wish I could...
I wish I remember exactly what the show was.
Because they had like...
I bought merch for it and everything.
And...
Oh my god.
It was...
It was like...
I wish I remember.
I wish I remember exactly what it was called.
Because it was basically like a musical performance.
And...
I remember my parents...
I was so obsessed with Doraemon.
That...
My parents bought like special tickets for like...
Front row seats for it.
And I bought almost all the merch.
I had like the umbrella.
The shirt.
The sweater.
And everything.
I bought almost all the merch from the show.
And it was like one of my happier memories.
Because it was...
Oh my gosh.
It was such a...
I was like...
There they are!
Oh my god!
I was so happy.
I was so fucking obsessed.
And then I loved like...
Dora...
And because of that...
I was obsessed with dorayaki.
But like...
Every time...
Oh my gosh.
What is it called in Cantonese?
豆沙包.
我好鍾意豆沙包。
Like...
Oh sorry.
My brain just swapped to Cantonese.
But...
I was so obsessed with dorayaki.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
I would always want to eat dorayaki.
But I hated the taste.
I like...
I would...
I would like...
Force myself to eat dorayaki.
Because I loved dorayaki so much.
And I would be like...
Oh my god.
我鍾意豆沙包。
And then my mom would buy me dorayaki.
And then I would take like...
I would take like one or two bites.
And I was like...
Oh yeah.
I hate this.
But...
I would be like...
Oh yeah.
I forgot.
I don't really like the taste of it.
But I kept doing it.
I was like...
Do it for him.
Yeah.
So...
So yeah.
Like I always...
I always like eat half of it.
Because I just hate...
I just don't like the taste.
But I just love...
I just love dorayaki so much.
That I would buy it for him.
Like...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Paladin, thank you for the super chat.
Today is my 34th birthday.
What better way to celebrate than to watch a non-Marvel livestream?
Just kidding.
Keep up the great work, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat, Paladin.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Paladin.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Anyway, that is my history with Doraemon.
I'm super excited.
I have no idea what...
I think this is like a bakery simulator.
So...
We're gonna be...
It has to be more chill, right?
It can't be a stressful bakery simulator.
It literally has Doraemon in it.
So...
It can't be that bad, right?
I can't be like...
Like stressed out like the other simulating games.
Alright, let me get...
Dorayaki!
Oh my god!
There's...
There he is!
Oh, wait!
That's the other Dogman!
That's not the Dogstar Star.
Oh my god!
There's the other Dogman!
Oh, they're all like from the movies!
Oh!
They're all like from the Doraemon movies!
That's...
Okay, how do I...
Okay, we're using keyboard.
We'll do...
Start.
Empty.
Oh, there's our sister!
Nobita.
Zzzz.
Snore.
Okay, let's fix the...
Let's fix this part.
Let's put it here.
Snore.
Nobita!
Dai Hong!
Wake up!
Mom just showed me this leaflet!
Okay, if you guys want like...
The game is quite loud.
Okay, let me...
Let me turn it down.
Alright, I got it.
I got it.
Is it better now?
Guys, is it better?
Okay, backstory!
Okay, I'll give you guys a quick backstory.
A quick backstory of this entire show.
Of like the manga.
A history of like this...
Why they have like a codependent relationship.
So...
Nobita.
Or what I'll say, Dai Hong.
He is a...
Slacker.
So like...
He has no...
No future.
No goals.
No prospects.
Dumb.
He's just like me for real.
No ambition.
Middle class.
But...
No bitches.
All of that.
So like...
So he's basically like...
He was going to grow up like a deadbeat.
But...
Dai Hong...
Is here to stop that.
Because...
His son.
I believe it's a son, right?
Or it's like great...
Or like his grandson.
His grandson...
Hates his life...
Because of him.
His grandson...
Hates the life that he gave him.
So...
Great grandson.
I don't remember which one.
And was like...
And...
So it's the future.
And then he was like...
Doraemon!
Cause like...
In the future, everybody has these cat robots.
So like...
He was like...
Doraemon!
Get the time machine!
And help fix my life so it's not shitty!
Change my great grandpa's life so I can have a better future!
Basically generational trauma.
And he thinks that it all started because of Nobita.
Like as...
And so...
He also married his bully's sister.
So...
And so he's like...
He's like extra whipped, basically.
Because like...
He married his bully's sister.
So he's like incredibly whipped.
And so...
So...
Doraemon!
Came back.
Came to the past.
And be like...
I'm here to fix your life!
So your great grandson can have a better future cause it all started with you!
So...
That's the...
That's the background.
And the reason why he doesn't have ears...
Is...
Is because...
The reason why...
Also yeah...
Also they're really fucking poor.
Anyway...
So the reason why...
He doesn't have ears...
Is because he's afraid of mice and rats.
Because when he fell asleep...
The mice ate his ears.
So he's supposed to be a cat robot...
But he has no ears because mice ate the ears.
Which is really fucked up.
And that's why he's really afraid of mice.
There you go.
That's basically the entire story of Doraemon.
That's like all the story you need of Doraemon.
Because this is literally slice of life.
Like...
It's...
Yeah, he's bald now because of it.
So...
This is like a slice of life story and that's all you have to know.
It's like...
This guy...
What were his ears made of?
Also Doraemon used to have a really hot girlfriend.
But because he became bald...
She laughed at him and broke up with him.
So that's not really part of the story.
I just thought it was a fun fact.
He's bald just like me.
Oh and then...
Nobita owed money to the mafia at one point.
Because he was...
When he became an adult, he almost became a very successful businessman.
And then he like...
And then his company went bankrupt.
So that's why they're extra poor.
And that's why his great grandson...
Sent Doraemon back in time to be like...
Fix this!
That's just the lore.
So that's why.
Anyway, we're opening a Dorayaki store.
It says here...
That a new Dorayaki store has opened nearby.
Let's check it out.
Kaz, hey, wait a minute.
Both of you are very handsome.
That's messed up.
You're handsome too, Doraemon.
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz.
Thank you, thank you.
He also used to be yellow.
But I forgot why he turned blue.
I forgot the lore behind that.
What a fucked up way to explain the lore.
It's okay.
He changed his life so it's different now.
Now he's rich.
Apparently.
Now he fixed his life.
Oh, he cried.
Oh, yeah.
He cried a lot because his girlfriend left him.
And now...
And he didn't have ears anymore.
So...
And he's poor.
So that's why he's blue now.
Like, he cried...
He cried so much...
That he wasn't...
He turned...
He actually turned blue.
How come I didn't know about this?
Anyway, let's go.
Bro, what the fuck?
Are you sure this is the right place?
The shutter's down.
What?
Maybe they sold out already and closed for the day.
Hello, did you come here for dorayaki?
I'm sorry.
I injured my hand and I can't cook anymore.
No!
Not his dorayaki!
It's been my dream to open a dorayaki store.
I can't believe I would have to stop here.
Lore is so crazy.
I'm sorry to think you just made that up.
No, I didn't!
It's actually...
It's actually the lore!
I didn't make it up.
That's how the story goes.
I feel so sad for him.
I wish we could help somehow.
It's career ending history.
You know what?
You also want to have a dorayaki store in the neighborhood, right?
I sure want...
I sure want that, but what are you asking me to do?
I appreciate the thought, but I just have to accept my bad luck.
I couldn't ask you to help out.
The store is only in return for lots of dorayaki.
Lots of...
Lots of dorayaki?
You heard that, Doraemon?
That sounds like a good deal.
Oh my God, child labor laws do not exist in this game.
No, Nobita!
You're getting scammed!
It wasn't the dorayaki that swayed my decision.
I swear.
I just realized I'd be really happy to help run the store until your hand heals, mister.
It never existed, Doraemon world.
Let's get ready to open our doors to customers.
Okay, but first...
I got a secretary robot!
Yay!
Let me introduce you to your new assistant.
Oh no, I'm so thrilled to be working together with you.
I'll happily help you run the store.
Why don't we start by giving it a name?
Alright, Dora Nobi Sweets.
Alright, what should we name our store?
Nani's.
The children get paid.
Real.
Alright, don't worry.
We have to make sure we don't get arrested.
Guys, we have to make sure.
Okay, the children get paid.
Alright, we don't want the police to find out that we are breaking child labor laws right now.
The children get paid.
That's a great name for a sweets store.
Now, before we can open, we have to make some products to sell.
Select your kitchen or go to sweets from the menu to make your very first dorayaki.
Yay!
What do they sell there?
Alright.
I wanna make...
I wanna make new products.
You'll need this too.
What do you have?
I got a Sweets Inventy Bot!
They will assist you in making sweets.
Hello, nice to meet you.
I'm Wagashi.
Go ahead and try combining ingredients to discover new treats.
I'll be here to help if needed.
Ooh, the dorayaki patties.
Okay.
4,000 G's.
Now, new sweets, you can make one.
How do I make it?
Now, select the ingredients to combine with the base.
Okay.
Yay!
Maid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You forgot to tell since the manga didn't have an ending.
Everyone said that it was all Nobita's head and door.
I will never...
Don't!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Select looks good when you're done.
I mean, it looks good.
Yay, the dorayaki is ready!
What did I get?
What would you like to populate?
Where would you choose for finishing touches?
I feel like if we up the taste...
Then, like, the popularity would go up regardless, right?
I feel like that.
I'm gonna make the taste better.
Alright, dorayaki.
Put your dora juice all over it.
You got...
Oh, there we go.
Coming up with an attractive presentation, the product may enhance the quality even further.
The product presentation can be changed later.
Give it a go sometimes.
I don't know what he put on my dorayaki.
What did he do to it?
I don't even know what he did to it.
Let's have our local residents try our products and tell us what they think.
What do you guys think?
I might actually like it.
There's a niche for it.
It has its charm.
Won't put you out of pocket.
Oh my god!
Ruthless businesswoman going up...
In the world.
For a first attempt, that was amazing!
Now that we have seats to sell, we can open to customers!
The children get...
Don't look at the gun, children.
The children get paid.
It's now open!
It's April!
Oh, a dorayaki store?
Alluring sweet smells are wafting from the inside.
I think I'll take a look.
Alright.
It's April!
Oh, it's so cute!
What would you like?
We only sell one thing.
Dorayaki.
This is a huge store for like one thing I sell.
What is he doing?
What are you doing, Nobita?
Oh, I get to build!
What do I get to build?
Facilities.
Okay, what can I build?
Wait, what am I...
Oh, wait.
Do I like...
No, I don't want...
Back.
Oh my god, I'm a little confused.
Build.
Oh, that...
Oh, wait.
That moves.
Can I have seats?
Do I already have seating?
I already have seating, so I don't need to build that.
Removal.
What am I supposed to remove?
I don't want to remove anything.
I think everything looks good so far.
Add two customers.
Okay, manage.
Memories.
Not yet completed.
I don't have any memories yet.
Sweets.
Make.
I can't make anything yet.
I basically can't do anything until the...
Oh, I can train!
To improve staff abilities.
Staff abilities come in handy in a lot of situations.
So, it's well worth improving them.
What the fuck is he gonna do with yo-yo?
What is Doraemon...
Look at these sick yo-yo tricks, guys.
What am I gonna do with yo-yo?
Oh!
That's what it is.
Down and...
Right, left to see and choose where to build.
Wait, I wanna put a fishbowl!
I don't know what it does, but...
Um, look at my fishies!
Yo, look at these.
Yo, it's gonna attract the customers.
The Children's Good Paid has finally opened its doors.
The first customer in visit said...
Oh, he said that.
It seems that quite a few local residents are already frequenting the store.
Which might very well become an established feature of the neighborhood.
But will it attract customers from further afield?
We'll be straight to report on...
This has to be a really slow news day.
Like...
Oh my god, guys!
Front news page!
We have a new dorayaki store!
If only there was a handy tool that could tell us what our customers want to eat.
There is!
Right here!
What do you have in your pocket?
Daimon!
A mod reading?!
I should not be using this for dorayaki.
I'm like...
Oh my god!
I can read the minds of any citizens.
Of any villager here.
What would I do with this power?
Use it and you'll be able to see...
Exactly what sweets the person is craving.
And go ahead and try it on passerby.
What do you guys want?
I can see what they're thinking.
Wait a minute.
Whoa.
Why is one of them...
I can see...
Is that person with a sweet bubble?
I'll take a closer look.
Oh, by the way...
Is this legal?
That's true.
See if you can find a good use for it.
You got brown sugar.
Chestnuts.
White bean paste.
Alright, what do you see?
He wants brown sugar dorayaki.
He also wants chestnut dorayaki.
What else does he want?
It's very convenient to know what the customer wants to eat.
Try combining different ingredients to create the new sweets.
Okay.
I can do that.
Alright, Daimon.
We've only just opened, but we're getting lots of attention.
Let's see what it's about.
Wait, what?
Is it this?
Make.
Okay, so if I put white bean paste...
And then...
Looks good.
Then I get white bean paste dorayaki!
Alright, I wanna...
I wanna do...
I wanna do popularity.
That's it, make it popular!
Nobody requested this, but like...
Who cares?
I want it.
Hold a tasting event or presentation.
You can also just...
To do so, tap auto on the bottom left.
How do I make it more appealing?
Like...
Oh!
I like basically...
Alright.
Look at that red.
And then...
Do I have enough money?
Oh, and now I'm gonna make it bougie.
That's right.
Oh my god!
And then I'm gonna put...
This on it.
There we go.
That looks great.
Uh, massive!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
There's a really touching fan manga...
That said that Doraemon ran out of battery...
But Future Factory couldn't fix him.
So Nobita studied so hard...
Becoming the leader scientist of the world...
Just...
Just for saving his friend.
Oh my god, that sounds so sad!
Thank you for the super chat, massive!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Nice, we got it.
Makeover...
We fulfilled...
Wait, did we even fulfilled any requests?
I was not.
Any...
Something good might happen.
Hospitality for teacher?
I wanna try the chestnut...
Oh my god, am...
You want me to do this pro bono?
Hmm...
To be fair...
Nobita...
Is failing in school.
So like...
So like, this might be good, guys.
He is failing.
What do I do putting chestnut though?
Do I put red bean paste with it?
Oh, I do!
Oh my god, guys.
I might be able to bribe him to get a better grade.
Yay!
Okay.
Hold a taste event.
Alright, what do you guys think?
I might actually like it.
Might become popular.
I see potential.
Homie, but in a good way.
Teacher!
I did it!
You still can't a zero.
Teacher!
I made your favorite dorayaki!
Please, my mom will actually...
Oh, I...
Wait, what?
Did I just got an F?
Yay!
Enjoys five bean dorayaki, chestnut Mont Blanc, pink phone, and a Hearth Lounge.
Alright, we got an F, but that's a...
Oh my god!
Girlfriend!
I discovered a new story.
So...
This is...
Uh...
Suhong.
This is Suzuka.
Um...
And basically...
This is gonna be his future wife.
Um...
She could've married somebody better.
I'm just saying.
Before...
His great-grandson went and changed history...
She was gonna be married...
To like...
She could absolutely do better.
But she was originally...
Gonna be married...
To a guy...
That was smart...
Very successful...
And like...
Um...
And was like...
And very humble.
But then...
But then the great-grandson changed everything.
And...
Also like...
She sort of married him out of pity.
He was like...
She was the one that proposed to him.
And he was like...
Cause he...
It was very pitiful.
Cause he was like crying and was like...
I love you!
And then...
Suzuka was like...
And then she was like...
I can fix him.
I'll marry you, Nobita.
So...
That's basically how it happened.
Huh?
What are you doing, Nobita?
Hi, Suzuka!
We're helping out at this dorayaki store.
That's what you're doing?
On your spring break?
Wow!
Wait...
You don't mean you're actually making sweets, do you?
Massive thank you for the...
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome...
Stop roasting Nobita!
He's already gone through so much!
I am...
It turns out...
I have talent for this.
You can join us too, if you like.
I'll show you how to do it.
That's so cool!
Count me in!
But wait...
Are you sure I won't be getting in the way?
Of course not.
It'll be great to have you on the team.
Let's help out together until the owner gets better.
If you really want me to join you...
I guess I'll do it.
You said the owner was unwell?
Is this serious?
Hello, young lady.
Thank you for joining my helpers that totally get paid.
Oh gosh, you're hurt!
Shouldn't you be resting?
Free labor!
Yay!
It's not as bad as it looks.
I can manage most things without help.
But it's impossible for me to cook.
So these two are in charge making sweets right now.
I see...
Well, I'm happy to help too.
Yay!
I befriended Suzuka!
Hey, Doraemon.
Do you want to try making other types of dorayaki?
Sure!
But for that, we'll have to find new ingredients.
I suppose we'll need this.
The Anywhere Door!
I wish this was real.
I always wish that the Anywhere Door was a real thing.
Alright, where do we put the Anywhere Door though?
I guess since it can go anywhere, I can put it anywhere.
Let's just put it in the backyard.
Yeah, let's just put it here.
With this, we'll never be short-staffed again.
Oh my god!
And I get a copy bot?
All of this for one fucking store?
We can send a copy bot to search for ingredients for us instead of tasking staff members with it.
Yeah, basically the Anywhere Door is a fast travel door.
You think of where you want to go, and then you go there.
Alright, let's go and search for ingredients.
But where can we do that?
Leave it to me, Nobita.
Beep beep!
I found a place nearby that's perfect for ingredient searching.
A new ingredient nearby open space.
Let's go right away!
Let's use the Anywhere Door to go and search for ingredients.
Okay, how do I...
I don't want to do that.
Wait, training?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, it's right here!
Send out staff to look for ingredients.
You'll be able to find more types of ingredients when you lock new destination.
Alright, we'll get...
Nobita, because...
I feel like Nobita, because he has five.
I don't know what the five means, but I assume...
I assume it's good.
Alright!
Go and find me!
That's right!
Go and get food!
Alright, customer's request.
Oh, that's him!
Dekisugi!
That's him, right?
That was...
That was like Suzuka's actual husband.
Yeah!
Okay, that's him.
He's the guy that...
He's the guy...
That she was supposed to marry.
He was gonna become a scientist.
I don't remember if it was like a scientist or a doctor.
I'd like to see that new sweet story, but I feel awkward going to new places.
Do I have one?
Oh wait, I don't have brown sugar.
No, I don't.
Do I have this?
Oh, I don't have this.
Maybe you can make your recipes even better if you had a food lab.
Did you like...
I like how Doraemon...
Like, mailed that request instead of telling it to me to my face.
It's like a ominous letter...
But from Doraemon.
I wasn't sure there was something there, but I couldn't find it.
We might need to do more training.
Open the menu and go to helpers and then training to work on improving exploration stat.
Okay.
I have to do...
What do I have to do?
How do I do this?
Helpers, training...
Oh, it goes...
Okay, exploration.
Alright, everybody.
By being better at yo-yo, you'll be better at exploring, apparently.
We tried our best.
Okay.
And then, let's just do like...
Kodama, too.
The ting-tong dip.
Alright, now you should be able to...
Now you should be able to get more ingredients, right?
Oh, there he is.
He's still getting ingredients.
Okay, save complete.
I need a build facility.
Wait, I don't have it.
I don't have...
I don't have a food lab.
How do I build a food lab, though?
Okay, let's make...
I need to make a...
Brown sugar patty, yeah.
And then...
Red bean paste.
Is that not it?
Brown sugar toriyaki!
Wait, fanciness!
What does the fanciness do?
Make it fancy!
A woman touched it!
There you go.
Now that...
A very pretty girl touched it...
It should be...
It should be extra fancy.
Promising, yes.
There's a niche to it.
It's subtle.
Only in a good way.
Oh my god!
Look, I got your favorite food!
Instant markup.
The customer found something they like!
Handmade by...
Female.
Yay!
Enjoys a futuristic lounge in a book...
Am I gonna add a bookstore to my...
Fucking...
We're not...
We don't want loiters here.
I don't want any loiters!
Oh, nice.
Okay, I got memories.
Can I train even more?
Slime play?
The fuck am I gonna do with slime play?
Getting creative with slime!
How does this improve staff work?
Shooting practice?
Doraemon, I had this idea.
Why don't we offer drinks to the customers who have their sweets at the table?
That really is a great idea, Suzuka.
This is guaranteed to improve customer satisfaction.
I hope so.
We'll need to set up a drinks corner.
I found this big book while looking for ingredients.
It seems there's something on the other side of it.
Someone's inside the book.
Let's open it.
It won't budge!
What?
Is this for real?
I can see something on the other side of the book.
I may be able to connect to the...
What?
To the Kiteretsu Encyclopedia world?
What am I...
There's...
I'm just inviting the multiverse.
Oh, okay.
You're part of the world now.
The book's other side...
Oh, I remember this!
I remember the rabbit!
Oh!
A path to the other side of the book has opened.
Let's check it out.
Doraemon into the multiverse.
Where is this?
It's not the past.
It's not in space.
It's like...
My town.
But different somehow.
Metai-san, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bird noises to make my day better.
Thank you for streaming.
This does seem to be one of my ancestors' inventions.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Doraemon.
It seems we speak the same language.
Hello.
My name's Ichikikai.
You can call me Kiteretsu.
Sorry, but can you tell me what this place is?
It resembles my town, but it's different.
Well, I don't fully understand this yet either.
But it seems a strange book connected our world to yours.
We're so desperate for money...
That we're, like, grabbing people from multiverses to fucking eat from our store.
What?
Really?
I wonder how it works.
This is actually super interesting.
So Doraemon, is it okay if I come visit you here again?
Sure.
We're helping out the Doriaki store.
Come and check it out anytime.
And make sure to spend your money here.
Thanks.
I might bring some friends along next time.
See you.
It's like a dream come true to connect to a world that even a time machine can't reach.
Thank you so much for connecting us.
Yay, more customers.
Oh my god, we got your Doriaki in here.
Yay!
More customers!
Alright.
Now we have 10 customers.
Is he still collecting?
Holy shit.
Okay, what does...
I think you could use it.
Okay, maybe we'll do that instead.
Alright.
We're gonna get a drink corner anyway.
We have so much money.
It'll be fine, guys.
We're not gonna go broke.
Okay, so...
I have...
I can make another Doriaki.
Black sesame with red bean paste.
Huh?
No!
Okay, black sesame with white bean paste.
What?
Where do I put the...
Can I try again?
But...
I don't have anything else.
Black bean paste.
No...
I...
I wasted so much money.
I got the food lab.
I wasted so much money to make...
I didn't know.
Already reflected.
I got an encyclopedia.
Oh, that's from the book!
I get to go to the park with a pun?
Alright.
This looks like searching for ingredients will continue to be the key to creating a new sweet future.
Go in there.
Okay, who has the most search?
Nearby open space.
Wait!
I get to talk to a guy.
Okay, but like...
I want to talk to him.
He might be a new customer.
Go and find me more ingredients, me!
Alright.
Teacher request?
Okay, first we got to build a drink corner though.
Okay, the food lab.
First we got to build the food lab first.
If you run out of ingredients, you can go shopping for them.
Open the menu and go to match and then select shop.
Oh!
I can buy ingredients!
I can buy a fishing rod?
Okay, I think...
I should buy a fishing rod.
Oh, I have two.
Okay, um...
Oops, that's...
Oh, that's awkward.
I was not paying attention.
That is...
Now I have two fishing rods!
I mean, you can get mushrooms at the park.
Oh yeah, that's my bully.
That's Nobita's bully.
Who sometimes works with him.
And our friends, I don't know.
Their relationship...
They have a weird situation right now.
Um...
Hey, Nobita!
What are you up to?
Errands for grown-ups?
Daifan...
Like, we call him...
In Cantonese, it's daifanshu.
Which is like...
Big yam.
Um...
And you, helping out at your mom's store...
He's like part-time bully, you know?
He's like...
Yeah, as usual.
Doraemon...
Let's not tell Jen about the...
Doraeki store.
What are you whispering about?
Don't ignore me.
You trying to ignore me?
You probably don't have much to do anyway.
Right?
Come help at my mom's store too.
What?
Sorry, but we can't.
We got hands full helping at the Doraeki store.
Oops.
What was that?
A Doraeki store?
Now you gotta tell me more.
Okay, guys.
Mom said I'm free to help at the Doraeki store too.
Doraemon...
This is your fault.
Well, it can't hurt to have more volunteers.
I have a feeling we'll be getting busy.
Welcome to the team, Jen.
Thanks.
I bet it'll be more fun than my mom's store anyway.
Alright, so now we have my part-time bully helping me.
Bully who loves singing?
Yeah, I don't know.
It's weird.
They have a weird situation thing going on.
I don't know.
I don't know what really is going on up there.
Part-time bully.
Full-time worker.
Yeah, he can't sing.
He loves singing.
And like, part of his bully torture...
Is to literally...
Is to just sing to them.
And that's how like...
That's like apparently torture too.
Alright.
Nice.
The food lab is complete.
What do I do?
Oh, we can improve our existing recipes.
Go ahead and make your sweets even more delicious.
I can prime it?
We'll try it out once we decide who should be assigned to the lab.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, we got a drink corner too!
Okay, how do I assign this?
Shop.
Wait.
Yodoba store?
Oh, we haven't found it yet.
How do I...
Make your selection?
Select staff.
Oh, okay.
Um...
Let's put...
You know what?
I trust my bully there.
We'll put...
We'll put Jin in charge of the food lab.
He seems like he knows a lot about food.
Um...
You know what?
We'll improve...
We'll do...
The classic.
Oh, we can improve everything!
We'll do all of it!
Alright.
Uh...
They're looking for...
Tongari.
Who's Tongari?
Who's that guy?
Oh, Ji...
Ji...
Jian?
Is that how you pronounce his name?
I just know him by his Cantonese name, so a lot of the names are new for me.
Okay, how do I make this?
Whipped cream.
He likes bean paste butter.
Could really use a new folding screen.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm so rich.
I literally have 93,000 G's.
Fuck it.
Let's just build everything!
What's wrong?
What could go wrong?
Having children make the financial decisions of this...
Of this store?
What could go wrong?
My homework's so hard.
I can't do it.
Do you know anyone who can explain it to me?
Alright.
As a fellow child, I can help you do your homework.
Oh my god, we should get the other child to do it.
If the teacher finds out, it'd be pretty bad.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm gonna make sure...
I'm gonna make my future wife in charge of this.
Wait, does she get paid?
What do you mean?
I...
What?
I thought we're paying to buy with Dorayaki!
This is a scam!
Those children told me they'd work for Dorayaki!
How fucking dare they!
They told me they would work for Dorayaki!
What happened to my Dorayaki?
Dorayaki salary!
It's the name of a store.
Yeah, it's a name!
It doesn't mean...
It doesn't mean that...
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna make him...
I'm gonna do Pawn next.
I feel like...
Cause like, I'm tired of trying to find this guy.
Report from the food lab.
Did I make a better Dorayaki?
Plus 6, plus 4, plus 3!
Yay!
My Dorayaki tastes better now!
Oh shit.
Improvement results, plus 3, plus 2.
What about him?
Oh wait.
The teacher likes...
What was it?
It was the walnut, right?
Chestnut?
Yeah, it was the chestnut.
Oh, I can...
Wait, what the fuck am I gonna do with my fishing rod?
I don't even know what to do with my fishing rod.
Oh, I found whipped cream!
Nice.
I remember one of them really liked...
They really liked...
Oh, I should put more seats too.
I should add another seating arrangement.
Seating for two.
Uh...
Where do I put it though?
Maybe here?
Maybe I'll put it here, yeah.
More seating.
Can they access this?
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Oh, I can buy a folding screen!
Wait, actually I don't think they can access this.
Yay!
Oh, I met a girl!
It looks like they've safely found who they were looking for.
Yay!
New customer!
Oh my god, look at my profit margins.
I've got four customers, guys.
That's all my store needs.
My store only needs four customers to keep everything running.
Whoops, sorry.
That's all I need.
That's how you run a successful business.
Just four is all I need.
I will move this.
Let's make the most of today.
Oh, I got dough!
Make a sweet treat using Daifuku dough.
Okay, I should be able to make new ingredients now.
Right?
Whipped cream.
And red bean paste.
Yeah!
Whipped cream toriyaki!
When am I gonna go public?
Oh, get my vibes up!
Jian.
That's right.
Glaze it up!
Hold a tasting event.
Yeah, what do you guys think?
Promising, yes.
It grows on you.
I see a potential for this.
An affordable treat.
When can I start raising my prices?
That's right, that's all I need.
As long as I have those four people keep buying my toriyaki, that's alright.
Alright, he likes Ruth's menu board.
Okay.
I got a scene for two!
Another big book?
Does this lead to some other mysterious world?
Oh!
The books are like the crossover episodes to like...
The other stories, like the movie ones.
Is this for real?
I can see something on the other side of the book!
Connect me to them!
I need more customers!
Get me in the multiverse!
Uh, Chim?
I have no idea.
Who the fuck is Chimpure?
Who are they?
Oh, it's like an actual different...
Wait, it's like a different...
Oh, it's like his different works!
It's like his older works.
Yeah, the author's older works.
Oh, it seems this leads to Earth?
Fascinating.
I'll report this to my friends from Planet Mal.
Thank you so much for connecting us!
Yes, new customers means...
More money.
Which means...
More profit.
What does this make?
What is...
Oh, it's mochi!
Wait, I can even...
Oh my God.
I can even make mochi now, it's over.
I have mochi.
Hold a tasting event.
Alright, what do you guys think about my mochi?
Okay, technically they get paid now.
So, like, I'm not breaching any...
Any, like, illegal activity.
Doraemon, what do we do?
We actually made a sweet that's not dorayaki!
This is supposed to be a dorayaki store.
You fucked up, Nobita.
Why can't you do anything correct?
If it's tasty, why not try selling it?
The whore.
You had one job.
And they're happy, it's all good, no?
Oh my God, Doraemon is like...
His heart is...
This is supposed to be a specialist dorayaki store.
If we let mochi in, then what are we gonna do next?
Start selling pasta?
Why limit ourselves and deprive our customers of your newly discovered sweet treat?
Let's sell it!
Daifuku's shelf can now be built.
Alright, let's make a daifuku's...
Oh my God, it's my mom!
Although the children get paid has only recently opened...
The number of customers visiting the store seems to be increasing rapidly.
We managed to quickly interview one of the customers leaving the store with a beaming smile.
The sweets are just as I like them, and a wonderful atmosphere keeps me coming in.
It seems that the children get paid owes its good reputation not only to the quality of their products, but also the vibe of the store.
One of the customers was like, it's great seeing children around here.
Makes me feel young again.
It goes to show just how important it is to have good facilities for customers to use.
Make them happy, and you might find yourself getting a lot of valuable F points.
Okay, I...
What the fuck?
My sister?
Dorami?
What are you doing here?
Hello, Nobita.
Sorry, mom.
I brought you what you asked for.
What the...
That was quick.
I asked Dorami to compile some tips about running the store.
I arrange them by rank from the easiest to the hardest.
Complete the objectives one by one, and you'll become a top-ranked store.
Alright.
Clear the ingredient searches.
Get rid of opponents in your way?
Am I gonna...
What?
Am I...
Am I gonna fucking get a hit on somebody?
Like...
I see.
Well, let's start with the objective for the first rank.
You can check what the requirements are by opening the menu and going to manage and then rank up.
By the way, what do you think about making the store bigger?
I think it'll start feeling quite crap once you have a city full of customers.
Well, I gotta go now.
Best of luck.
Why did I need my sister from the future to...
To Google how to run the store?
Oh, to be fair, this was like in the 70s to 80s.
I'm pretty sure, right?
This was like...
Not even 70s, 80s.
This was like before the internet...
Okay, you know what?
That makes sense.
Google wasn't a thing yet, so I needed my sister to Google in the...
I called my sister to Google for me on how to run a successful store.
And then she came back.
She printed Wikipedia...
No, she printed the...
The how-to page.
The wiki how page on how to run a store.
And then gave it to me.
Thanks, Doraemi.
Bye.
Doraemi's right.
We could use a bigger store.
And have just a gadget for it.
Doraemi asked ChatGPD.
I gotta expand the...
Goodbye, homes.
This is Doraemi.
I'm gonna bulldoze this land.
Wait, can I not?
Wait, can I not take this over this?
How do I use this?
Goodbye.
That's right.
I destroyed several.
I Thanos-snapped them and now they're gone.
What happened?
Where did they go?
Wow.
And then the children are like, that's so cool.
Let's build an extra space with all sorts of facilities to make our customers happy.
Good.
Anything for Dorayaki.
Alright, I should be able to build...
Oh, there you go.
I needed to build this.
Eviction for Dorayaki.
Oh my god, I got a lot of food there.
What?
Oh, I got the hill behind the school.
Go again.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
I don't know if I should, like, find this guy or not.
Nah, we'll just explore.
Let's find my dad.
I think my dad's missing.
Let's go find my dad.
That's his dad, by the way.
That's Nobita's dad.
He hasn't came home.
He's at the park at the open space and I think...
I think I gotta find him.
I need to build this shelf.
Okay.
There we go.
Yay!
Now my mom will acknowledge me!
Oh my god!
My mom now finally loves me!
I'm not a failure in her eyes!
Oh my god, finally!
Also, it's really sad because Nobita's dad rarely comes home.
Because he's always out drinking.
And then he always comes home drunk as hell.
And then his mom always has to be like, Why are you always drinking?
And then, like, it's pretty fucked up.
But then they make it as like a joke and everyone's like, Oh, there he is!
Out drinking again!
You got funds!
Yay!
Nice.
Do I have anything new?
Oh, I got the folding screen.
Where do I put the folding screen though?
Oh no, do I put it outside?
What do I do with this?
What is the purpose of a folding screen?
I guess I can just put it here.
Oh, it's just like reputation!
I got a request!
What does he want?
Request.
Oh wait, what kind of food?
Okay, they want flan.
Bean paste butter.
Matcha.
Oh, you're right, I should get a swing.
Is he still doing her homework?
How hard is his homework?
How- Why am I still doing homework?
What do I do with fishing rods?
Oh, okay.
Oh, he's gonna buy two dorayakis now!
Alright, I'll give it to my teacher too.
Nice.
Oh my god, I found my dad.
I'm gonna find my dad.
Dad!
Oh my god, I'm getting rich.
Oh my god, do you see that?
Oh my god, you finally finished your homework!
How did that turn out?
Tutored a student expertly.
So that homework was completed with- It's been- It's been- He's been gone?
I just need you guys to know this.
He's been gone for three weeks.
Like, I- I don't know what was going on with that homework.
Wait, what do I want?
F points or money?
I'll take F points, actually.
I feel like F points is better.
Dad!
Oh, back to four months!
Oh my god, we finally- It's been four months!
Oh shit, Suni!
I forgot what his name is in Cantonese.
I always- I hated him the most.
I actually forgot what his name was in Cantonese.
And I've never seen his Japanese name before.
It's- Ah, what was it?
Suni- I don't know how to pronounce it.
Uh, Sunio?
Okay, yeah, he- Okay, so...
Sufu?
Is it Sufu?
Um, okay, so...
So- Alright, now you know why he's- He's very annoying.
I'm going to the department store with my dad!
He's gonna buy me a new RC card!
Okay, alright, so...
Um...
Context behind Sunio...
He is basically...
The very annoying rich kid...
Um, that brags about, like...
All the new stuff he's getting...
From, like, all the new shit he gets.
Um, and like...
He was, like, the bully's, like, henchman.
Basically.
So, like, if anything goes wrong...
He always blames on Nobita.
So, like, even if, like...
Nobita didn't do it...
Uh, the bully would be like...
WHO DID THIS?!
And then Sunio was like...
It's Dai Hong!
And then I'm like...
He had no need to say that.
Like...
It's Nobita!
He did it!
But, like...
He would just blame him for no reason.
Yeah, he's a little rat.
He's a fucking little rat.
That's why I always forget his name.
I never liked him.
When in doubt, blame Nobita.
Alright, what's your story?
You little rat.
Huh?
You guys are all here.
Hi, Sunio.
What are you up to?
Going to the department store with my dad.
He's gonna buy me a new RC car.
Oh, hey there, Sunio.
Good to see you here.
Jian!
I...
I gotta go.
Bye!
Aren't we lucky, Nobita.
Sunio's gonna help us too.
No, why do I get dragged into this?
The moment I saw Jian, I knew this wouldn't end well for me.
Wrecking!
What's a wrecking?
Can I hire somebody to do that for me?
Yay!
I wish I didn't befriend him, but yay!
Boastful!
Okay.
A boastful narcissist.
I did not expect that.
From Doraemon.
Alright.
I got my boastful narcissist here.
It's true.
The worst.
The lie.
I did not... Damn.
I did not expect him to, like...
I did not expect him to actually, you know...
Wait, let's do shooting practice.
To, like, actually, you know, roast him like that.
Yay!
I feel like we can upgrade a lot of stuff.
Oh, wait, this gives, like...
Shooting practice gives the most upgrades, so I might as well just save up for shooting practice.
Uh...
And then...
I'll just save up.
I feel like shooting practice does the most anyway, so it's the best.
Can I make anything new?
I did red bean paste, right?
I'll do white bean paste.
And then black sesame?
No!
Which one to go for?
We'll get F.
F.
F points.
Yay!
Yes.
What can I make with...
Red bean paste?
What?
Brown sugar?
White bean paste?
What?
What do I do with it?
I give up.
Uh...
Oh, no, I can't.
I already paid for it.
I don't know.
I never made mochi before.
I don't know what people want.
Have I not found...
Wait, do I not have enough whipped cream?
Doriaki primer?
Chestnuts?
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna buy stuff.
Okay, let's improve our Doriaki.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I got to build a swing now.
Okay, build.
Swing.
Guys, I have a swing.
Please come to my store.
I have plus two rep.
Oh my god.
Why are they all so demanding?
I have so many demands.
What do you want?
I could really... Fine.
I have the money anyway.
Alright, fine.
That's cool.
I can do that too.
I don't have matcha, bean paste.
I don't have butter.
I don't have...
Yamogi...
Mochi?
I need mochi dough.
Mugwort?
The fuck is that?
Wait, flan is made of soy sauce?
Okay, I need butter.
Oh my god, I could've just looked at these recipes.
Oh my god, I could've just looked at recipes.
Why did I...
Why did I try to...
Why did I try to experiment?
I actually wasted so much money for doing that.
I wasted so much money experimenting on cooking.
I don't have...
I have to discover butter to get like...
Oh, I found mugwort!
Okay, what was the recipe again?
Sweets...
Okay, it's like customers...
It was my dad.
Mug... Oh, I need mochi dough.
I don't have that.
Manage... Memories...
Okay, I acquired memories there.
Is there anything I can...
Improve?
No?
Uh... Training?
Oh, I can... Oh, I don't have shooting practice.
Uh...
I don't think I can build anything though.
I already...
I guess I can put this in here.
Okay.
Now we wait.
Oh, my mom asked for something.
What does my mom want?
I think your...
Can use a lounge?
I think your store could really use a...
Anything for you, mother.
I'll do anything.
I just want my mother's love.
Please love me, mom!
Hahaha!
Hello, everybody!
Coming from the raid!
My name is Doki Bird!
Thank you, Mozul for the raid!
Nice.
Now my dorayaki is gonna taste even better.
Okay.
Uh...
I don't know what...
I don't know what this does.
Oh, it just... Oh, it just says, like, their opinion on, like, my food.
I see.
Wait, what's this?
There's one request that caught us up.
Oh, I can build a tea room now!
And a menu board!
I found another big book!
Oh!
I know this one!
This one's really old.
Is this for real?
I can see something on the other side of the book.
It's Perman!
Oh, that one's, like, one of his older works, too.
Hello, Perman.
You're connected to the universe of Perman!
Where am I?
It's a bit different from our town.
Have I traveled to a different world?
It looks so fun.
I'll be coming here again.
More customers!
Oh my god, that's what I like to see.
More customers equals more money!
I'd like there to be more drinks on the menu.
What does he want?
Okay, I don't know.
I don't know how to make that, sir.
That's a little funky for me.
I don't even know how to make that.
Alright, customers, items, charm up...
Wait, what?
What's this items?
Try using it on a facility?
I mean, I could just increase my parasol.
Now it's 25.
You know what?
Yes, increase it even more.
Now it's 28.
I might as well.
Oh, I could...
I didn't realize if I read more of it, it would tell me what it increases for.
Oh my god.
I forgot to read.
I forgot to read properly.
Alright, uh...
I think he would like it more.
Yay!
Now he's gonna buy more!
Oh my god!
He invented another customer!
Yippee!
He invented another customer to buy more!
Alright, I can build a hearth lounge.
Oh, and then a tea room.
Wait, I should build that.
Okay, I'll build this here.
And then...
Oh, nice!
I got sky plaza!
Go again!
Wait, hopter is required for...
Oh, I don't have the...
What do you mean I don't have it?
Like...
Go there, right?
What?
Okay, the hopter is like...
It's like a famous tool.
A famous gadget.
Where like, you fly around with it.
I'm like, what do you mean I do not have it?
Oh, okay, I had to send them away for repairs.
This time we'll have to buy them from the future department store.
Oh, by the way, you'll need this when you go to the future department store.
I got future coins!
Shall we see what they have?
Okay, we got the future department store.
Alright, Mr. Future.
I need...
Oh my god.
I know I could buy...
Okay, but like, what if...
What if I buy this instead?
I'm...
I know...
Guys, I know...
Look, I know I needed to buy the...
The hopter, but like...
What if I buy this instead though?
Oh...
Okay, good.
I can still afford it.
And I'll buy the... Oh!
The memory bread.
I used to be so obsessed with this, and like, I would I would dream about this being real.
I would dream and like, fantasize about like, I wish this bread would be real.
And then like, in my imagination, I'd just be like, god, if this bread was real, my life would be so easy.
What does this do?
So the memory bread is literally, you write down something you need to learn, like basically something you need to learn on a test, and like memorize it, and then you eat that bread and then you basically remember it forever.
Alright, I'm back from the future.
Oh, hello!
How are you?
Wait, is this my great-grandson?
How are you, Doraemon?
Doraemon, you told me you're helping out at the dorayaki store.
Hello, Sawashi.
It's nice to see you.
Hello.
I'm actually looking for some secret gadgets that could be useful at the dorayaki store.
How about this, Doraemon?
I can lend it to you.
Doraemi?
I didn't know...
Oh my god, look, don't ever talk to me or my son again.
Doraemi?
I didn't know you were coming.
You'll let me borrow the mini Doraemon?
Oh no, he's stupid.
He's saying he'll be happy to help out at the dorayaki store.
Now I'm curious what that dorayaki store is like.
You know, great-grandpa never talks about it, so clearly...
So I think something happened, Doraemon.
He's my special little man.
We're back!
I got mini Doraemon!
Mini Doraemon will be useful at the store.
What does he do?
But like, what does he...
The famous inventor, Kaito Iechi, has finally succeeded in developing the robot of his dreams.
In an interview with a magazine, Kaito says enthusiastically, I've named the robot Kurosuki.
It feels amazing I've constructed this robot at last.
This has nothing to do with me.
Why is the staff here?
Why is the dorayaki staff who agreed to be photographed?
Like, why are we here?
This isn't even a story about us!
They're like, anyway, here's a picture of the staff of the dorayaki store.
It has nothing to do with this mess.
Genius!
It's like we have an interview of a scientist who like maybe invented a cure for cancer and then next to the picture was like here's the staff at a KFC who agreed to be photographed.
Wait, who's that?
Who's he?
Nice to meet you.
I'm here with a request for the children to get paid.
Could we use the children get paid sweets as prizes for the neighborhood raffle?
Yeah, let's do it!
Alright, uh...
I feel like classic dorayaki.
I mean, you can't go bad with a classic.
It could be a place where customers just hang out and relax in the fresh air.
Why not?
But don't sneak out there during work hours.
No way I won't do that.
Let's get that baking lot set up then.
What am I...
What does that come here?
Do...
Build...
Uh...
Where is... Oh, tea room!
Yeah, I wanted to make the tea room.
I'll put it like...
here.
Or like, should I just put it... I don't know.
Do I just put it like...
Maybe I'll put it...
I'll put it here and then start...
No, I feel like I could put it here.
And then I'll like, expand the pathway.
Yeah, and then...
A path from the store.
We need like...
Okay, I can make a path.
Guys, I...
Please, there's so many updates.
Okay, corridor.
Door.
There we go.
Boop.
How do I... Oh, there we go.
And then...
Please.
Please!
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
Easy.
That's one request to cross off our list.
Nice.
Yeah!
I got lemon juice!
And orange juice!
And acerola juice!
Make my juice.
How do I make juice?
How to make juice?
Hello?
Oh, drink cereal.
I feel like...
You don't need to be happy.
I need my F.
I need my F points.
Okay, can I make this yet?
Okay, I have money.
I don't need to worry about that.
Oh yeah, what does he like?
Syrup and mo...
Dude, I don't have any of those ingredients.
Like, what do you want from me?
What does my son want?
Or my great-grandson want?
Oh, I found a missing child!
Oh no, he's looking for another missing...
My missing child is looking for another child.
Alright, well, I don't know where he is.
I'm sorry.
What the fuck does Mini-Mi do?
Is he just walking around?
Like, what is your purpose?
I don't know what...
I don't know what Mini-Mi's purpose is.
He's just walking around.
Okay, I can still improve my dorayaki.
Nice, I acquire more memories.
Oh, I should train.
This exploration...
Oh, this costs less.
So yeah, you basically...
Paste the bread on the book...
And then you remember stuff.
Alright, keep doing it.
He's just...
He's doing his best.
Okay guys, he's just...
He's just existing.
Oh, did he like my dorayaki?
By lots of people.
Some people joined in just to try and win.
Oh, yay!
They tried to join the event to win...
An item that's 100 yen.
That's when you know...
It's good dorayaki.
Let's go!
It's just 100 yen...
But fuck it.
What did I get?
Oh my god.
30,000 dollars for 100 yen dorayaki?
Let's fucking go.
Oh, I got Bonsai.
Bonsai!
Can I build anything else?
Oh, I can build a tree.
Just my little fucking shrub.
There you go.
You guys like my shrub?
It's tiny.
Oh, I should put the menu like...
Next to it.
So they know exactly what they're seeing.
Oh wait, it's inside.
Okay, nevermind.
Um...
It still works!
It still sorta works, guys.
Um...
Did I just unlock this?
I don't remember.
What's an Eve's?
The fuck is an Eve's?
I don't know.
Oh wait, that's the third pie.
We don't need pie.
My cool shrub.
Oh my god!
Stonks!
Oh wait, it went down.
What?
How did it go down?
This doesn't make...
What?
How did my stonk go down?
Like...
What?
Not stonks.
This doesn't add up.
I have my...
Takecopter.
Let's have MiniDoraemon join the ingredient search too.
This way, we'll get even more ingredients and items.
You can select whether to take MiniDoraemon along on the screen or choose to go ingredient searching.
Alright, go.
Go and help me find MiniDoraemon.
Oh my god, I got a vacant lot.
It's time.
I got cherry leaves?
What am I gonna do with cherry leaves?
Oh wait!
New item!
Oh, I can buy Mugworth!
But like, it doesn't matter.
I don't need Mugworth right now.
I wanted to build a vacant lot.
So like, my staff members can hang out.
Jesus Christ, it's a huge area.
Wait, I can't build it?
Oh, I guess I have to build it here.
Why do I need a pathway?
Oh, I need to put grass there.
I was like, am I gonna build inside?
Okay, and then right here.
It's so hard to like...
It's really hard to move around.
Okay, as long as people love my dorayaki, that's all I care about.
15 families could have lived in that dorayaki.
No!
Who dares interrupt my nap?
I'll make you... Oh my god!
There's the boss fight!
Oh my god!
I was like, wondering what the fuck they meant by boss fight.
Nobita and friends have arrived.
I have a boss fight?
What is he doing?
Oh my god, they're beating them up.
Oh my...
Get out of here, cloud boy!
Get out of there, cloud men!
I'm here to urbanize your area.
Holy shit!
Nobita!
Oh my god, three more!
It's up to you!
Oh my god!
Jihan!
Jihan, it's only up to you!
Jihan, let's go!
He's protecting his property.
That's right.
This is Nobita.
This is Doraemon land now.
That's fucking right.
I own this place now.
He did it.
The bully's done it again.
That's fucking right.
Do I...
Is this connected?
I cannot tell if it's connected.
Oh, what book did I get this time?
Is this for real?
I can see something on the other side of the book.
Connect.
I have 35 F points.
Give me more customers.
I'm gonna be a conglomerate.
Is this Japan from a long time ago?
I didn't have to use my rocket to go on an extraordinary adventure.
A whole city explored.
Thank you for this opportunity.
Okay, I...
I know that...
I know that I'm mochi dough now.
And like, several people wanted something with mochi dough.
Okay, mochi dough, mugworms, and red bean paste.
Oh my god, I can finally make it.
I can actually, finally, fucking make it.
Oh my god, and I got butter!
Everything is moving up in the world.
Okay, it was Mugworth, and...
Oh, I already forgot.
Guys, what was it?
I remember it was like Mugworth and something.
Guys, what came with Mugworth?
Was it red bean?
It was red bean?
Okay.
Make this...
Glaze it up.
Glaze up my mochi!
Nice.
Oh, it looks nice.
Alright, what do you think?
Yeah!
They all see potential.
They gave me plus one rep.
I'm here from the Dorayaki Promotion Association.
Oh my god, we gotta...
Guys, we have to...
What was it?
Improve, right?
Wait, what was it?
Helpers.
Helpers, sweets appraisal.
Seeds with higher charm will make a better impression?
I only have one.
Charm 22?
Let's wait and see what happens.
Okay.
Guys, this is good.
We might get a mission and star for this, guys.
Just give it all to the teacher.
Yeah!
Now I'm gonna get an A plus for real.
Okay, we gotta...
Build a mochi shell.
There it is.
I thought that was also mochi.
I guess it's different mochis?
Dad!
Will you finally acknowledge me as your son?
Oh my god, he's...
My dad will...
I won't... I won't have daddy issues anymore.
He finally loves me, guys.
My dad finally loves me.
He knows I exist.
Alright, let's see.
I don't have strawberries yet.
I know there is one where I can make.
What is this?
Butter, red bean.
Okay, butter, red bean.
Let me see real quick.
Uh...
Make...
Butter...
Red bean.
Yay!
Increase the taste!
I got my dad's approval, guys.
Maybe he'll finally say I love you and give me a hug.
After he goes...
After his...
After he's done drinking, of course, because drinking is more important than spending time with his family.
Toki, why would you...
Because that's actually in the story, guys.
I wish I was joking, but he actually...
He goes out to drink instead of spending time with his family no matter what.
It's a problem.
Yay!
Now he's gonna visit my store too!
Pricing cat.
Customer satisfaction has activated.
Come here, cat.
It's a shopping fever!
Bye, bye!
Sell, sell!
Oh my god, I get to go to the desert palace.
Alright.
Oh hey, there's a monkey.
Oh no.
A ghost blocks my way.
There's no way.
I feel like I can beat the ghost.
I can beat him.
Alright, I might need to train my...
I might need to train my helpers, actually.
Let me make sure my helpers survive.
Let me make sure.
I'm a little scared.
Alright, I hope you guys don't have peanut allergies.
Eat the peanut!
Oh my god.
Okay, I gotta make sure my...
We don't know if they have peanut allergies or not, but... Oh, musical performance?
Why would I pay $10 to make sure none of them have it?
Get that protein in!
Get it inside you!
Alright, let's see.
Rank up.
Oh, I can rank up!
Yeah!
Hello!
I heard you ranked up, so I rushed over right away with my wiki how page.
It's incredible you got your first star so quickly!
Here's a reward for you!
Enjoy!
Congratulations!
What did I get?
I got... Oh, I got permissive...
Persimmons!
And then... Oh, I got like cute decorations!
I discovered a new story?
Shooting stars.
That store was so busy today.
It really is hard work.
Oh, look!
That's so pretty!
It's a meteor shower!
Doraemon?
It is hard work helping out a store, but I really enjoy it.
You do?
Yeah!
Making sweets and seeing the customers really love them?
It's so amazing!
Wow!
That's weird you never told your grandson about this, about how you opened a sweet store.
I wonder what happens in the future that made you not talk about it ever again!
lol I wish we had as many customers as there are stars in the sky tonight.
That might be a tall order.
But I'm sure we'll meet a lot of people at this store.
Oh, foreshadowing!
lol People from all sorts of worlds.
That'd be great!
Okay.
We better get some sleep.
The rest is up for tomorrow.
I have soursauce!
I can make fun!
Here are the conditions.
Alright, here's page two of the wiki how!
Raise my rep.
Discover new sweets and get the sweet store served.
Okay, so I need...
I need more sweets and then I need to discover more sweets too.
Alright.
The children gets paid rise to popularity seems unstoppable.
We just received a report of a mysterious new device installed at the store.
The come here cat as it's called activates when customer satisfaction reaches a certain level, triggering a sweets fever.
When that happens, passerby feels irresistibly drawn to come in and buy some sweets.
A customer we interviewed after such a shopping frenzy told us I had something else today.
Isn't this illegal?
I feel like...
Isn't what we're doing illegal?
Like...
I don't know.
It doesn't feel like natural.
Yeah, it feels a little bit suspicious here.
But we're not being investigated so...
I had some guys are like, Toki, you literally read somebody's mind to figure out what their dorayaki sweets is and it was definitely not consensual.
Let's do more illegal things!
Let's...
Let's go!
Oh my god, slightly reduces hospitality cost.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
What's this?
Score better in tasting events.
Enables you to build the indoor fishing pond.
Enables you to build a dream freely.
Okay, we need this because the tasting guy is coming over.
Alright, we have to get this in so like when the guy comes over to taste...
Okay, how do I activate the tool though?
Items.
Wait, perma set?
Don't I have perma in there?
Oh, he's not in here yet.
Wait, how do I activate it?
How do I activate the...
How do I activate it?
I don't know!
Oh no.
I don't know how to activate my...
Oh, maybe he like comes over.
Oh, it's a passive.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like thinking it might be a passive then.
I think it has to be a passive.
Oh, let me put a tree in here.
Alright, nice.
Plus one.
What's the new quest?
Oh, I got a new story!
Oh, it's my future wife again!
You've got a lot more customers now.
Isn't it great?
Yes, but we can still deal with a lot more.
But, how do we go about tracking more customers?
Hmm, let me think.
You know who likes sweets besides...
Ants!
Oh, alright.
He's cooking enough.
No more cooking.
Actually...
Wow, the world is full of humans too!
Let's invite customers from afar to come and visit us!
That's a great idea.
How can we make it easier for customers from afar to visit us?
Well, how about... Are we really running a shuttle bus for a fucking dorayaki store?
Like, we're like...
Hello people visiting Japan!
Let me take you to this really tiny dorayaki store run by children!
Now, I know in the west that child labor is very frowned upon.
But you're in Japan!
And in a specific place in Japan where like...
Do not worry!
It's legal!
This will become the terrorist spot!
Okay!
That's it!
Let's do it!
I can't wait to see who comes to our store!
And I hope they'll love it!
Alright.
Oh no, I see the ghost.
I see the ghost.
I see the ghost at the bottom.
He's ready.
He's ready to fucking fight me.
Do I have matcha yet?
No, I haven't discovered matcha.
There's like one I can make.
I'm trying to...
Okay, I can't make this yet.
Can I make this yet?
Okay, I don't have soybean.
Alright, let's get the...
And then get the glass partition for it.
Oh, there he is!
It's time to fight!
This is my turf and you're not welcome.
You made a big mistake coming this way.
Alright everybody, it's time to fight.
I know you live here.
But like, this is my house.
This is my home now.
The opponent did something mean.
That's right, I'm gonna beat you up and take your lunch.
But oh my god, Nobita, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh no, Jian.
Jian, yes!
Jian the bully!
Don't eat my mouth.
Alright, uh...
I think I can build more, right?
Okay, I got this.
Uh, I'll build... No, I don't wanna build this yet.
Uh, oh, I can train more.
Okay, let's eat more peanuts I guess.
Oh my god, eating peanuts costs 10 now.
That sucks.
Or like, costs 16.
It gets more expensive the more I use it, I noticed.
Holding memory...
Okay, Nobita, like...
What is your purpose, Nobita?
What...
What is your purpose anymore?
What do you do?
Hello everybody!
We're gonna go camping!
Yeah!
Nice.
Okay, they all loved it.
Because if they didn't, I would've left them stranded in the woods.
So I'm glad they all loved it.
It was a lovely picnic!
I had so much fun with everyone!
Let's do this again sometime!
Everyone had a good time, I'm so glad we did this!
Oh, another big book.
Oh, which world is this?
Is this for real?
I can see something on the other side of the book.
Yes!
No!
My F points!
I don't have enough.
I don't have enough F points.
I actually don't have enough.
How is this possible?
Okay, I'm gonna charm...
I'm gonna charm up my seats.
Nice.
Okay, now I'll charm this up too.
My F points.
First it was my rank words, now it's my F points.
Wait, do I have new gadgets?
No, I don't.
Can I buy new stuff?
Oh wait, I can!
I really wanna save up.
I wanna get the treasure finder.
When is the critic gonna come?
Oh, I got matcha!
Yay!
I actually got matcha.
Okay, I can't improve anything.
We don't find anyone to judge at the painting competition.
It will get cancelled.
Please help.
Someone help me!
Oh wait!
My mom!
Don't worry, guys.
My mom will judge your painting competition.
She has no other... She has no painting skills.
But that's okay.
Oh wait, I ran out of seats.
I should build more seats, though.
Honestly.
Put it here.
And then... Oh my god!
It's time to expand!
Oh, goodbye neighborhood!
I'm sorry, every time...
Every time I like...
Goodbye neighborhood, it's my neighborhood now.
We don't know what happened to those people.
Oh, I got shuttle bus!
And I got glass partition.
What happened to them?
We'll never know.
We'll never know what happened to them.
Oh, uh...
I still want... Wait, do I have any of them that's stronger?
No, nobita is the strongest.
Oh, okay, so now I finished everybody.
Let's go to the hill behind the school.
Alright!
Yay!
Uh...
Items... Oh, I get marble.
Mom, take my marble!
Oh my god, look!
Look!
People from other side!
Hello, this is a new hit tourist destination!
Hello, everybody!
My new...
My most hit craze tourist destination right here!
Wait, can I rank up?
Uh...
Make... I can make two, but like, I don't know the recipe for it.
I'm too worried to experiment on recipes.
I'm pretty sure...
I don't have enough.
Let me check.
Double check.
Oh, I do have matcha!
Okay, matcha red bean.
Okay, I can make that.
Uh...
Matcha red bean.
Yay!
Matcha teriyaki!
I don't know.
Make it taste better!
Put your magic... Put your magic juice in there.
Alright, tasting event!
Oh, it's my new record!
Oh, plus three!
Alright, monkey.
Here's your matcha teriyaki.
Yay!
I got matcha teriyaki!
Wait, what does Qian want?
Qian, what do you want?
Doraemon!
Can I talk to you for a minute?
Sure, what is it?
So my mom's story's doing really well.
And she's been in a great mood lately.
That's great!
Yeah, but here's the thing.
I scored zero points on the last test.
I will tell mom at some point, but I'd like to get her in an even better mood.
Okay, and how are you planning on to do that?
By increasing sales at all.
Um, what do you mean by that, Qian?
Yeah, that might work.
Right?
Okay, then.
I'll leave it to you, Doraemon.
What?
He's bad in the product launch.
It boosts sales, I think.
I know.
I'll try my best.
I'm too soft-hearted.
You see, if I don't do that, he's gonna beat me up.
And I really don't want him to beat me up, guys.
Like...
I feel like that's understandable, right, guys?
I really don't want him to beat me up.
How do I...
Oh, I guess I find more ingredients.
I have to find more ingredients to be able to beat him up.
Or not be able to, like, satisfy him.
Wait, what was the one...
I had a new character that asked to...
Oh, it's the strawberry.
I just don't know where to find strawberries.
I have to pay him to increase his store?!
Okay.
That's crazy.
I have to pay him to, like, fix his store.
I don't have strawberries.
It says I can make new items, but I don't know what the recipe is for it.
Just a small loan of $10,000?
What could go wrong?
Honestly.
Um...
28 F points.
I feel like I already increased the F points.
Plus 3.
And then, I'll do seeding as well.
That's just extortion.
I pay him and he's extorting me.
I just need...
When is my thing gonna get...
When...
When is the critic coming?
I thought...
They're not...
Oh!
Oh, he's already...
When is he gonna...
I just want my certification.
When is he... Oh, okay.
Do you know anyone with great sales who could help?
He didn't give me a certificate.
Don't worry.
I got my smart boy.
My smart boy is here.
Why didn't he...
Why didn't he give me my certificate?
I demand my certificate.
I'm gonna put this here.
And...
The...
Did he not like it enough?
I don't understand.
I thought he liked it.
Did he not like my...
My dorayaki?
Where's my...
Where's my certificate?
Certificate!
Go!
I need another event to happen?
Oh my god.
How many events do I need?
Let's see.
Okay, I need more money.
I need more future coins.
And...
Can I afford it yet?
Wait, when the fuck did I spend my future coins?
Did I get like...
Who stole my coins?
Who the fuck stole my coins?
I...
I had future coins.
What happened to them?
Wait, it is a dino egg!
Oh my god, that's a dinosaur egg!
Okay, uh...
I got glasses.
I'm gonna give it to my mom, cause she always needs glasses.
And then...
I'll give it to...
I'll give it to him.
He's smart.
Oh my god, there we go.
I invested in dinosaur eggs.
Mom has returned!
How did it turn out, mom?
Unleashed her inner art creator and did an amazing job at the... Yay!
25 rank points!
I mean, F points!
Okay, we need more...
F points.
We're like...
We're so low on F points right now.
Okay, now that we have F points, we should be able to connect to this world.
I've connected to the Esper Mommy!
Have my psychic powers grown so much that I can travel between worlds?
Since I'm here, I'll have some fun!
Wait, that's it?
That's all he's gonna say?
Oh, potential new customer.
What do you want, customer?
Can I make it... Okay, whipped cream...
Red bean paste.
Whipped cream...
Whipped...
Whipped cream... Did my cells go up?
Oh my god!
That's right!
Stonks!
Stonks right...
Oh my god!
44,000!
That's fucking right, guys!
That's all I needed!
Never sell!
Hahaha!
Always believe!
Okay, it was...
Oh my god, what did she want again?
Yeah, hold it!
To the moon we go!
I think it was like...
What is it?
Daifuku dough...
Whipped cream, red bean paste, dough...
Dough...
What is it again?
Oh, whipped cream!
I don't have whipped cream!
Okay, okay.
I need to buy whipped cream.
Uh...
Oh my god, I almost bought this.
Okay, I need to buy whipped cream.
And then...
It's okay, I can make it.
Uh...
Whipped cream...
Red bean paste...
Yeah!
Get the popularity up!
Nice!
Okay, hold the tasting event.
Plus three...
Plus three!
Are you happy?
Are you happy about my store?
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Doki, we get it.
You miss Marvel arrivals.
Nice.
Oh my god, handsome...
Handsome Doraemon.
Oh, I have all of them!
Oh my god, I got all three.
Granny?
What do you want, Granny?
I'd like to promote one of the children as something to have on the go, but which one?
Um...
I'm gonna do this.
Because it has more stats.
Always pick the one that has more stats.
I think that's all I can improve.
I want my certificate!
Okay, so I just need him.
Guys, why don't I have my certificate?
How do I...
How do they...
Why don't they like my...
Why don't you like my food, sir?
Sir!
Please!
Like my food!
Why am I not certified?
What do I do?
Why doesn't he love my food?
I don't understand!
Alright, we don't have to explore anymore.
Oh!
He's here for the appraisal!
Oh my god, he's finally here!
Oh god, this is it.
This is it.
Oh my god, he bought my dorayaki.
Oh!
He bought it!
This is it.
I'm zooming in.
I need to know.
There it is.
Okay, granny.
I don't care about what you say.
I was attended by...
It seems that Wawa has become a trend.
Yay!
It's not premium...
Oh my god, supply and demand.
And I got $40,000.
Oh my god, what does he think?
I saw his announcement.
10 out of 10.
30, 20, 20.
It's a perfect score!
We did it.
I have finally become certified.
Who would you give it to?
Oh, that's difficult.
Maybe I should just give it to Chen.
He just gets everything.
Oh my god, who would I give it to?
I don't know.
I mean, he gets more energy if I give it to...
I'll give it to Raimon.
It was his cooking, you know?
It was his cooking that did it.
We didn't expect too much...
Since you've only just opened...
And it's also run by children, too.
To be fair, I feel like you shouldn't expect much...
Just because it's run by children.
Keep making wonderful treats...
The children gets paid.
I can't wait to see what other delights you'll create.
Yay!
20 future coins.
Nice.
Oh, I get to improve my Mochi!
Oh my god, we've finally been certified.
How did that turn out?
The product sold out almost in an instant...
And the store was swamped with orders for more!
F points.
Always go for F points.
I don't need future coins.
I need more F points.
Okay, I can rank up now!
Yay!
I'm two Michelin stars!
Professionals.
Professional took 20 years to get it.
It only took me four months.
Wow!
Of course, I prepared an award for you this time to congratulate you.
I have a boulder and a lamp.
I feel like...
I feel like my sister...
Literally is like...
Giving away junk from her garage.
She gave me a fucking rock and a light.
A lamp.
Like, I...
I literally...
I got a perfect score and she gave me a fucking rock.
Hey, I've been thinking...
How do your sweets compare to other stores?
I don't know.
Never thought about that.
If our customers like them...
Isn't that all that matters?
No, Pita.
You're so naive.
There are tons of dorayaki stores out there.
If someone else starts selling better sweets than ours...
We'll lose our customers!
Oh no, that would be awful!
We need to have some sort of an idea about how to compare our rivals!
But everyone's personal preferences are different.
We gotta have a monopoly!
We gotta destroy the com...
We gotta start competitive pricing again.
A sure way to tell our products are good...
Would be entering a contest.
A contest you have professional judges assess the sweets.
Oh, that might be a good idea.
Let's try entering a contest.
If we win and we get the dorayaki association stamp approval...
It's gonna do wonders for our rep!
But not winning doesn't mean our sweets are not good at all.
So let's try to win.
But remember, it's not the end of the world if we don't.
Of course!
No, if it doesn't win...
That means our sweets are dog shit!
And then we should give up and sell our business.
Oh, I get to go to the Misty Forest.
Let's send a child to the Misty Forest.
Raise my rep.
Get a Fujiko character.
Win a contest.
Oh, hey!
They have new products!
Um...
How do I enter a contest though?
Oh, there he is!
Let's do it.
Uh...
Alright.
Oh my god, so many decorations.
Oh my god, I'm gonna bougie this shit up.
Alright, 8,000.
That's right.
We're gonna put that in here.
And then we're gonna...
I told you the F points.
I told you the F points is gonna matter.
Alright, there we go.
And then, uh...
5,000.
That's right.
Bam!
Um...
E, D, E, D.
Alright, we're ready.
Maybe we should change the dorayaki though.
Maybe.
What is my best dorayaki?
49, 19.
Bean paste, 34.
49, 60.
Oh my god.
I think my chestnut one is my highest rated.
Yeah, it's the chestnut.
Alright.
Who is it going to?
Doraemon.
Alright, let's go.
Today, confectioners from all over Japan compete for the best quality sweets.
I'm excited.
If we...
If we lose, I'm ending my career.
To me too.
Looks like the con is about to start.
Alright, let's go and watch the judging.
Wonderful!
Oh!
Delicious!
Okay, we literally got 100 from all.
Like, there's no way.
Yeah!
Which career?
We did it!
Fucking easiest contest of my life.
Depends on where the dorayaki stops.
Holy shit, 200,000.
Okay.
I don't feel like I need more money.
I feel like we just need points.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, maybe 100,000.
That's fine.
Yeah!
Okay, 100,000.
Oh my God.
Goodbye, other city.
And they're gone.
All for the sake of desert.
Not my home.
Guys, you don't understand.
You don't understand.
This is important.
This is for...
Oh wait, I can enter this.
Alright, if we don't win this...
If we don't win...
Wait, actually, can I improve my daifuku?
I've never improved my daifuku, but...
If we don't win this, I'm actually ending my career.
Okay, change presentation.
Use that.
And then we'll put that on.
And then...
We'll put that.
And then we'll also...
We'll put all of this in.
If it tastes like shit, at least let it.
Alright.
We're ready.
Doraemon.
You get to have it again.
I'm just gonna buff Doraemon.
Oh no.
Alright, let's see how it goes.
Fantastic.
The best.
Wonderful.
The best!
That's fucking right.
Yeah!
You might as well close down your store.
What do I get from here?
Oh, this one should be easy.
Stop giving me money.
I don't need more money.
Please.
Stop giving me more.
I need other stuff.
Okay, I'm still...
I'm gonna have...
The most expensive...
Oh wait, maybe I should have this.
Alright, the most expensive presentation.
Alright, here we go.
Doraemon, off to you again.
Fantastic.
The best.
Wonderful.
Fantastic!
That's right!
All you professional chefs.
That spent years.
Your loco mochi store.
Your specialty is mochi.
And you lost the children.
Quit your job.
Clearly, this was never your career in the first place.
You might as well quit your job and retire now.
Oh my god, thank god.
I finally got points.
Thank god.
Yay!
Alright, guys.
I think after...
Sweeping the contest.
I think that's a good way to end the stream.
That was fun though.
That was a fun time.
It was definitely a nice like...
Oh hey, there's my one above all by the way.
Oh, sorry.
It was definitely like a nice just...
Chill session.
And just to like...
I feel like I can definitely play this game a lot.
Offstream.
And just like...
It's like one of those mindless games.
Where you just build and build and build.
Yeah, we own the fucking market.
And like just...
Like mindlessly just keep building.
It's a very comfy, chill game.
I really enjoyed it a lot.
And it was nice like...
Revisiting my childhood.
And like...
Explaining...
The lore of Doraemon to all of you guys.
It's funny how you guys were like...
That can't be the story.
But it really is.
It's funny that a lot of you guys forgot that...
Nobita owed like a lot of money to the mafia.
Because he like...
His company burnt down.
And everything.
And then they became really, really poor.
And you guys were like...
No, that can't be the real story.
Like...
They like...
They like put it in there like...
In the beginning of the chapter.
So like a lot of people forgot about it.
But I...
For some reason, I remembered.
That was like one of the stories that...
Like that was one of the lore parts that...
I remember from the story.
Papa, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Thanks for showcasing a Kairosoft.
Be careful though, they're secretly comfy addicting.
Yeah, it's pretty addicting.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
But I'm really happy to be able to...
Showcase you a...
A portion.
Just like explain to you about like...
Something from my childhood.
That I grew up with.
And it's definitely been...
Really fun just playing it.
And just being comfy and you know...
Enjoying a game that...
Just like a...
Not like high...
You know, not a FOMO game.
And just something that's just a relaxing...
Game of just...
Opening a door...
A sweet, a dorayaki store run by children.
But yeah, thank you everybody.
I'm gonna relax now.
I can feel my voice dying today.
So I'm gonna relax...
For the rest of the night.
Thank you everybody for coming.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!
I'm also gonna get dinner.
I haven't had dinner yet, so...
I just had my like...
Bread snack.
But yeah, I'll see you guys.
Bye bye everyone!
Bye!